what does programming look like in 10
years right and my first sort of real
approach to this my first actual time
and I was tasked with trying to figure
this out of it was as Fernando said and
Microsoft so I was a program manager on
visual studio at Microsoft and as time
went on I originally started as a
program manager on the editor and
eventually came to own the experience of
using c-sharp and visual basic and while
I was there I sort of carved out this
little interesting position for myself
which is trying to figure out what
Visual Studio will look like years from
now what is the future of Visual Studio
if we were going to make this
programming thing better if we were
going to make programmers more efficient
what would it look like and in order to
answer that question I managed to
convince my superiors to let me do a
study and I and so I did the to my
knowledge only ever done and to end
study of Visual Studio where I sat
behind a one-way mirror and watch people
program and solve problems on a computer
and this sort of very general set of
tasks for a month and a half right and
as a result of that I gained a lot of
sort of insight into what it means to
program what it means to be a good
programmer right and how we actually do
it
and this is important because as an
industry we're actually not very
introspective you know I loved it we
would have these guys who'd come in I
only use the keyboard I never ever touch
the mouse right well we have videotape
of them using the mouse about half the
time right it turns out that depending
upon what tasks you're doing what what
your mental processes are kind of doing
at a time you have different modes of
operating and one of those modes
typically is done with a mouse not a
keyboard and so I I did this this study
and started to design what I thought the
future of programming would kind of look
like it's specifically tool oriented
right like that that was what I was
tasked with I wasn't looking so much at
the languages or any of that there was
somebody else whose job that was and so
I built a bunch of interesting you know
prototypes and stuff and they've been
slowly trickling out of my
or soft since then but this is where I
first started right I started at
Microsoft on Visual Studio imagining
what programming will look like in 10
years and I'm like it would be really
faster right right
that's that's kind of where I got to and
it will be it will not only would be
really faster right but you'll be able
to navigate really efficiently right
these were the two things that I sort of
latched on to and that study also taught
me something very important and that
that what that thing was led me to the
next project which was lighttable right
and what that study taught me was that
despite as Fernanda said Visual Studio
is a monument to humanity it is 55
million lines of code when I was there
five years ago right it is a gigantic
piece of software but in that study I
found out that most of the things that
are in Visual Studio weren't actually
helpful they could have been right they
could have been useful it wasn't that
the features themselves weren't good but
they were dwarfed by the fact that
everyone was playing computer inside of
their head this was how they came to
understand the software that they were
working with this is how they came to
understand programs they were unfamiliar
with even once they were familiar with
when something goes wrong right your
only action is read some code imagine
what the computer would do right and
play it out in your head write some
stuff down and just keep doing this over
and over and over again until eventually
you have basically simulated the program
and you found your error right the
premise behind lighttable was what if we
were directly connected right what if
there was no time between change and
result what if we shortened the feedback
loop to effectively nothing and I think
you know there were many interesting
ideas I think in my table but the one
that people really latched on to was
what I called at the time the insta
repple and the idea was you typed code
on the left-hand side and if there was
anything that ran as a result of that on
the right-hand side you'd see the code
filled in with all the values right so
if we you know kind of zoom in on it
right so you know this is enclosure so
it's a lispy syntax but if I add 3 & 4
it shows me that the answer is 7 so I in
do some math and then what's interesting
is this this def end thing is a
function right and so the function takes
two arguments and you can see they got
filled in as well and you can see what
the result is and what this enabled was
as I typed it did this so I could
literally watch the data flow through my
program right I there was no question
what was going on when I said that
people were forced to play computer
inside of their head what they were
trying to do was make the program
observable right they were given this
sort of opaque thing with a set of
instructions explaining how it works and
the goal here was let's just open the
box and let you see inside of it and
that was that was really interesting and
it was useful and there's lots of very
neat things that came out of light table
I mean it had other ideas too you know
it had this sort of small talking notion
of like I'm gonna put code like little
snippets of code all over the place and
embed running applications in it so that
you know I can sort of create my own
organizations for code right I'm not
limited to just what I can put in a
linear file I can create this sort of
canvas upon which all this stuff sits so
we did light table and one of the things
we we had sort of an explicit goal of
right was not just unlike a Microsoft
where the goal was purely like make
programmers more efficient our goal with
light table was actually yeah we want to
make you know me more efficient that's
great and all that has potentially huge
economic value but more importantly we
wanted to make programming more
accessible right one of the things that
we we came to was this idea that the
reason programming is so hard is because
it's unobservable because you can't see
what's going on you can't see the
effects of change you can't you know
watch your data flow through and so
you're doing this this replaying in your
head and like table you know with
features like this yeah any we're pretty
good for programmers actually you know
that that study that I did for Visual
Studio we kind of replicated it with
light table to see what the difference
was right and for a career programmer
hey programming this way it's about
twice as fast and there are lots of
interesting things that came out of that
for example in Visual Studio people
would write
large swaths of code before ever trying
you know before ever pressing the play
button basically with this model people
wrote little tiny bits right and we're
trying it all the time and as a result
of that they built up as they were
building up sort of abstractions and and
you know all these functions and and
this sort of set of primitives
they knew what every single one of them
was doing they knew it worked correctly
they knew what their result was going to
be and so that was great you know career
programmer could be maybe twice as fast
turns out that twice as fast actually
isn't enough you know this is this is
something that people have sort of a
religious attachment to right these are
our tools these are the ways we express
ourselves as programmers and so 2x while
interesting and compelling is not enough
to get me to drop Emacs right or is not
enough to get me to get out of Visual
Studio or whatever the case may be so it
didn't really get the the sort of
attention we had hoped for in that
regard although you know we got tens of
thousands of people using it more
importantly though it did nothing for
our other goal this goal of making
programming more accessible and we try
to understand this and that
understanding resulted in an essay that
I wrote a while back called toward a
better programming and in it I sort of
realized that I had approached this
problem you know I I you know I used to
say I want to make programming better
right and I realized I had made a
classic rookie mistake which to this
room is probably well known and
understood I try to answer a question I
didn't really understand right like what
is making programming better mean what
is better that that implies that there's
something wrong what is wrong with
programming what even is programming
right is kind of an interesting question
to start to ask and so we started doing
some research we asked a bunch of people
build a bunch of prototypes tried to
sort of develop an understanding for
what we were actually trying to do and I
sort of came to this to an answer about
what is wrong with programming if we're
going to do anything to fix it we have
to have some notion of what it is we're
actually fixing right
and it came down to three properties the
first I basically already started to
talk about right
it's that programming is unobservable I
make a coat or I make some change in
code unless I manage to execute that
code path you know in manual clicking
around on a screen or whatever I have no
idea what happened and as I'm making the
changes if I make a whole bunch of them
I have no idea what the effect of each
individual change is much less the
effect of the entire aggregate of
changes and this is a lot of what we
were trying to address with light table
was trying to make programming more
observable but there's another problem
too and that is the programming is
indirect so if I'm let's do something
fun if I'm describing a drone right and
I have this thing hovering over here
next to me if I want to make that drone
do something using pick any language you
want right I have to first translate it
into that language I have to first
translate it into the computer right I
have to I have to think like the
computer in order to get the computer to
do what I want is this very indirect
mapping and if you look at the vast
majority of errors that happen when
people program they come from actually
relatively simple translation errors
right as this indirection that causes a
lot of friction so when we were doing
that that study on visual studio we saw
this over and over again where somebody
had the right solution just along the
way they just did it slightly
incorrectly and again it wasn't that
their logic was incorrect or any of that
it's just literally the mechanical
process of translating that logic into
Python or C sharp or whatever is not
easy we're not very good at it as human
beings and the last one and this is
something that career programmers really
latch onto when I talk to them is that
programming is incidentally complex what
I mean by that is that the vast majority
of what we do when we program has
nothing to do with the problem we are
trying to solve right a very very simple
demonstration of this is I like to pick
on how long does it take to set up a dev
machine from scratch right I watch
people take the better part of a week
doing this at Microsoft
that's just to get code
run right that's like not even trying to
do anything interesting yet that's just
to get started to start your problem
right and so when I say that that
programming is incidentally complex I
mean that we spend a great deal of time
solving the problems around solving our
problem so to give it a simple example
of this to sort of demonstrate exactly
how hard programming really is right we
tried to come up and we did this talk a
while back where we went around and and
had a bunch of people try to build what
we thought was one of the simplest
possible programs you could imagine a
normal person wanting to build which is
a button on the screen that counts the
number of times it's been clicked right
and so you know I can click the button
it says one and two and three and that's
it right if you think about this like
what it takes to build this little
button we'll assume you already
understand HTML which is a big jump
right but we'll assume you won't know
enough to write this little bit of HTML
here and then it's not so bad right it's
just six lines of JavaScript well let's
unpack exactly what's in the six lines
of JavaScript so first off you have to
understand the notion of identity which
is arguably one of the hardest problems
in programming even though it seems like
it should be something very simple you
know I have to tell the computer hey
that button that I just put on the
screen I'm still talking about that
button I want to work with that one
right
you then have to deal with scope right
this this again six lines of code has a
function in it which is creating a new
scope and things are weird in this sort
of world things that you define in there
don't escape but if you talked about
them above there they're ambiguously
escaping you have the notion of mutable
assignment vast majority of programming
errors are the result of mutable
assignment you have closures something
that still most career programmers don't
understand correctly you have a
synchrony which is probably
unquestionably the hardest problem in
programming at this point you have
objects and properties and the Dom that
six lines of code contains the context
of years of work right you have to have
spent years to
understand what all of those things are
doing yeah sure somebody might be able
to go to stack overflow you know copy
some of this out and tada I have a
button that works but that means they
can't change it cuz they don't
understand it right those six lines of
code you know I joke here like too long
didn't read for six lines but that is
kind of the reality right programming is
hard question is does it have to be hard
right is this is this sort of intrinsic
my standpoint is no but this is where we
ended up with light table right we had
taken these this kind of language we
took JavaScript we took closure we took
Python we're like well if we remove the
feedback loop programming won't be easy
now right because you don't have to play
computer in your head but this didn't
change all of this is still true right
all of this is still necessary and so as
a result of that it you know didn't make
things much better and that's sort of
this sort of like fundamental problem
with trying to make it more accessible
right as programming is still
programming no matter how good of a tool
you make for it and the problem with
that is that these languages and these
tools were built around the idea that we
were going to build applications right
that the end result of programming is a
little icon that you double-click on
your screen and does one thing and
somebody writes it and they give it to
you and that's that but the reality is
what we really want when I started to
think more about what it meant to make
programming more accessible it wasn't
about making applications we struggled
with this for a long time right we're
like oh well it's going to be building
website so we'll make it easy to build
websites right but it's actually to do
something far more fundamental right
it's just to think like if fundamentally
if you go back to the beginning of of
you know the 1970s when when a lot of
what is modern computing came to be the
idea back then wasn't the single purpose
appliances right the idea was a tool to
think with and if we're going to make
programming more accessible ultimately
what we are trying to do is make a
thinking tool not necessarily a tool for
building large-scale applications right
because at the end of the day the
computer is the greatest thinking tool
ever developed right if I know the
magical incantation necessary to punch
holes in this card
I can get the computer to think for me
right and that is a hugely hugely
powerful thing you know when we went
around pitching this to folks we labeled
it a superpower because that is
fundamentally what it is it was one of
the only times that given a computer you
can start with nothing else and create
something of immense value right just by
knowing how to punch these holes and so
that would that's what sort of
ultimately led us to this project that
we're working on now that projects name
is Eve and it is this idea okay I
started with with visual studio trying
to make programmers better realize that
the tools are actually not all the
problem right it's look like the model
of programming itself is a problem got
to light table like hey the feedback is
now there so that makes it observable
but it wasn't quite the way there and it
was still a tool right we're still
approaching this from a tools
perspective Eve is what would happen if
we tried to solve this problem from the
ground up right ignoring basically
everything that exists what would you
build if you could if you could have
read if you could basically imagine
building programming today right so the
first net first approach to this of
course as a programmer was to take all
of the things we thought were good about
programming and all of the these sort of
trends that were happening like
functional programming immutability and
all of these things we'll put them all
in a pretty little package and that's
just going to work so the first
prototype of this was the thing that I
showed at at Strange Loop which is a
which is a software conference no is it
not playing oh there goes it was a
software conference that's sort of like
deals with a lot of the more interesting
sort of avant-garde ways of thinking
about the world and so the idea was okay
we'll take functional programming in a
mutable data and we will put it in
something that looks a lot like a
jupiter notebook right
and we'll make it so that you're like
literally working with the data right I
like right-click on a thing and I tell
it what I want to do with it and you can
see all
results and don't get hung up because it
doesn't look super great at this point I
built this prototype in like four days
but it was really interesting because it
took a problem that would normally take
quite a long time better part of a day
for example so this was taking a bunch
of data out of [ __ ] doing so usage data
out of [ __ ] and then doing some some
math on it and then getting a graph out
of it right and all this again was done
by just sort of like dragging and
dropping and right-clicking on some
things and there were a bunch of
interesting ideas in this one is the
idea that you're always kind of working
with the domain itself so you'll see
here in a second when I want to write
out some math I actually do it in math
and by that I mean mathematical notation
zoom ahead here I'm apparently being
slowed right so you know I want to sum
over all the X's and divide it by the
number and today I have average yay so
the idea was write like you're working
if you're working in a domain let's say
for example I have my drone example
again right if I'm working with a drone
there's a drone on the screen right
instead of describing a set of
operations that I'm performing I just
move the drone around right and it's
capturing what those steps were and then
I can parameterize them by data or like
get a chart or whatever I'm trying to do
right so this was interesting and we
took a much better much prettier cleaned
up version of this we're like this is
awesome we can build all sorts of things
with it later in the video I show I'll
skip ahead
I feel like building a website this way
where you know you just have these tree
of functions that do stuff and it was
interesting and cool as a programmer it
was very exciting and I happen to be at
the opening of Brett Victor's laboratory
CDG in San Francisco and there were all
of these non-programmers brilliant
brilliant people physicists and
mathematicians and all these people
there don't know how to program and we
set like I said a much better version of
this in front of them and like try it
right we're like we were excited we're
stoked this is we're done this is gonna
be amazing and actually the reactions
were really positive people liked it
they they thought it was really
interesting they got why they would want
to use it
and then much to our horror we watched
them not be able to do anything in it
right and I will never forget the
reactions we got which was they were
trying so hard right and and they were
very well-meaning they like they
genuinely wanted this to work so they
were like willing to do things that most
people probably were not really willing
to do but there was this thing that
surprised me this thing that they
struggled with out of all the things
that I expected to find out in this the
hardest thing for for the non
programmers to work with with scope so
in functional programming you end up
with these deeply nested set of
functions right everything is about this
magical tree of functions that you're
going to call and the the reactions that
we got were really obviously bad so like
somebody would look at it and go you
know they had some data up at the top of
the function stack and they they had a
some calculation they wanted to do at
the bottom of the stack right and
they're like I want this down here and
you're like I don't look at I mean oh
well you can't I mean you'd have to pass
that through all of these and you can't
really do that and they're like mmm I
don't understand it it's right there why
can't I use it here right okay fine if I
can't do that can I use this up there no
you can't really do that either we'd
have to thread it through going back up
right it was like this really I I no
longer believed the arguments I was
making because you're like trying to
understand like well scope is really
important right like you need it for
functions and functions are really
important and I don't know that's like
something we can't do right and so we
try to do a bunch of things we try to
make this nicer right like okay well
we'll make it look prettier and we try
to do a bunch of things to make the
scoping thing less of an issue so there
was no variable shadowing we had a much
simpler version of scope we do arrows we
colored things the same we try to do all
of these different things nothing worked
it seemed like it was kind of like just
this fundamental problem that was really
hard to get over and so that led us down
this very odd line of questioning which
is well if
if our first attempt at this what the
industry seems to think the future of
programming is is like I said functional
and immutable and yay if that's not
right and scope is a kind of a problem
which basically encompasses all the
programming where do we go from here
right like what does it mean to remove
scope from programming so if you think
about it
well scope can't functions so that's
already scary to begin with it also is
that when you're building up these like
nested data structures that you have
there they're like creating scopes right
you're like starting to worry a lot
about where something is in this tree of
data and you don't want to duplicate
because you've put that data somewhere
and you put it in another place then
they're gonna be out of sync and you
have all these problems there's another
version of the scoping problem so you
can't have functions
you can't really have data structures if
you don't have data structures you don't
have anything that can keep things in
order anymore so you don't have ordering
so if you think about what programming
is if you asked a career programmer what
programming is they would probably say
an ordered set of steps typically
executing functions over a set of data
all of that falls away if you remove
scoping and so we started to look into
well has anything ever worked this way
right and there is at least one
massively successful example that works
exactly like this and that is Excel
right so Excel has a single data
structure but you don't work with the
data structure directly it has no
scoping if I can see a value I can use
it anywhere it has no inherent ordering
it has scalar functions but you're not
like nesting these deeply right you're
writing out basically equivalent of a
mathematical formula and it never goes
deeper than that so it has all these
properties and that is a fantastic
result and also a terrible result but a
fantastic result first it is a fantastic
result because 800 million people use
Excel every single day it is
unquestionably the most accessible
thinking tool available to us and people
have done amazing truly amazing things
with Excel I I was telling the story at
lunch that I
had this opportunity to talk with some
folks at a fortune 500 company right and
this cruise line and they have this
spreadsheet there was ten gigs in size
they had been built up over a decade no
professional programmer had ever touched
the spreadsheet but it modeled the
entirety of a fortune 500 companies
business they could have nuked every
other system and run it off of this
spreadsheet right this is amazing like
totally utterly amazing and so that's
great now at the same time Excel is this
is the downside Excel wasn't meant to do
that kind of thing right so that you
know they were joke around they're like
yeah if we made any changes to the
spreadsheet we had to go to lunch
because it took an hour and a half for
it to propagate right and Excel is
constrained right as a two dimensional
grid of numbers if your problem is not
easily specified as a two dimensional
grid of numbers kind of out of luck so
we looked a little bit more and we found
that there was one other case that
worked this way again massively
successful and that is relational
databases relational databases have the
same set of properties right they don't
you know if you can see a value you can
use it anywhere if you can see a table
you can use it you know barring access
rules basically there's no inherent
ordering either to the code the
execution any of it right even the data
has no inherent ordering you order it as
you will and again no like deeply nested
functions or any of this crazy scope
stuff going on you have basically
functions and scalar values and that is
a great result again certainly not
accessible like Excel but it is it
solves the other side of the equation it
is a flexible thing right the world runs
on relational databases at the end of
the day basically every bit of data ends
up in one of them and we have built
games and websites all the things you
couldn't imagine really building in
Excel so we discovered this like hey
relational databases is an interesting
case let's see what people have been
saying about them recently right there's
got to be stuff other than Postgres out
there that we can look into and that's
where we ended up on research out of
here actually Joe Hellerstein
lab the boom lab had been working on a
language called bloom and they were
working on that language to do
distributed systems the idea behind it
was that it was a query language so a
little bit like sequel but it was based
on data log and you can if you know what
Prolog is it's kind of like prologues
little cousin and it does a lot less and
it's a lot simpler and is able to be a
lot faster as a result and they were
building distributed systems so they're
like reimplemented hadoop right and
we're like oh that's really amazing
because it was orders of magnitude
smaller and all these great things could
we build a website this way right like
could we take this maybe stretch it a
little bit think about it in a slightly
different way and how far could we take
it so I built this prototype this is
ultimately actually the prototype we
raise money on and it's a very
interesting thing because if you read
what these little things do we had an
intuition which is that prologue right
or data log or any of these is written
in predicate logic and predicate logic
is pretty hard to get your head around
but if you think about it it kind of
looks like fill in the blank sentences
like those mad lib books we had when we
were kids right it's like put a color
here and if you squint and you think of
it that way if you think of these
predicates sit that way and you think of
horn clauses as like when you see this
thing do this thing you get this kind of
very natural way of thinking about it so
this is the incrementer button right
that little button I was talking about
before say like well when I'm setting
defaults remember that the counter is
zero and when the counter has a value
draw this button and when that button is
clicked change the counter is whatever
its current value is to the current or
to the value plus one right and so like
I said we built you know interesting
things out of it we always build two new
MVC because that's what everyone builds
but sort of building interesting things
out of it and we started to realize this
crazy way of programming you know that
has no data structures has no inherent
ordering when I built this prototype
originally I didn't even have
aggregation which is interesting sort of
made us realize that a lot of the things
we think are fundamentally necessary for
programming just aren't they just you
don't need them at all actually and sort
of as an interesting
sample this not only yeah we built this
website and you could say all well
that's a toy or whatever the IDE that it
was written in was written in it and I
know a thing or two about building IDs
at this point I built a few you know
visual studios 55 million lines of code
light table which does far less than
Visual Studio and was designed
specifically to be as small as humanly
possible was over 10,000 lines of code
this was 600 right we're talking about a
totally different way of thinking about
the world not only was it 600 lines it
was written in a week in a language that
had no tools that didn't even have
aggregation right like I had bugs in it
and we still managed to write this in a
week and so that is a tremendously
awesome result that you know we can take
some of the things that that Joe's group
had learned about distributed systems
and apply them more generally to these
other places and if you squint at this
it starts to kind of look like one of
the Holy Grails of programming right it
kind of starts to look like an
executable an english executable
specification right I read it to you and
if you think about the the description
you would give of the increment or
button it's not very far from this
except maybe the wind setting defaults
part of it right and that's obviously
pretty surprising and and like really
interesting right again this is one of
those things we've wanted for forever
but we found out that actually this way
of programming isn't that great the
whole I I you know a lot of people still
think that the English specification is
is like the future of programming if we
ever get there we've made it and we're
kind of done and I no longer believe
that's true the reason why after having
programmed this way for a little while
is that if you read an English
specification every line of that English
requires you having understood and
internalized every previous line that
was written right if you think about a
big part of what what makes programming
hard right or a big part of dealing with
complex system is being but box parts of
them up right like I don't need to know
about this I don't need to know about
this I can just let go with this and
these English specifications required
you to basically understand the whole
thing all the time
and yeah they were shorter so maybe you
could reasonably do that
but when we actually tested this out
with people and sat them in front of it
they were like I can read these programs
I get what they're doing no one was
successful in writing one right which is
kind of interesting and yeah you mean
you could argue maybe it was our tooling
maybe it was our strategy maybe it was
whatever but I think it's probably
actually more fundamental than that like
I said I think it has to do with this
context problem that every line requires
the context of all the previous lines
and so we get okay let's try something
totally different
we know this Excel thing works what
could we make it look like Excel right
and so we started to realize that these
operations you could perform visually on
tables because that's basically all that
was going on here and so in this example
it's gonna be a little hard to see so
don't worry about it too much but what
I'm doing is this is the first time
you've interacted with the outside world
it sent us a text message and so we did
we have the set of buttons down here at
the bottom which you can't read but it
has our names on them and if you clicked
one of those buttons it was going to
send that person the text message and
the way this worked was that there were
these tables inside of our system that
you know had like event information in
them and had the people in them and then
we would join those two things together
and now you can see every time I click
on one of these it has the information
for Chris or Jaime or Rob and has a fake
version of our phone numbers but we
actually did do this with our real phone
numbers at one point so it's kind of
like writing this thing in Excel again
with some more interesting abilities
than Excel usually has right we can join
things it had basically the properties
of a relational database and this was
this was neat it worked for some
definition of worked it allowed you to
do relatively simple things but we found
a bunch of problems with it for one once
you had this nice little table you lost
all context and where any of this
information came from which when you're
building things is actually pretty
important information to know you just
have these values they just have kind of
like random names but it did kind of
prove to us that you could start maybe
treating this as a very different
problem maybe instead of thinking about
like writing code even if it were
English
code maybe you could think of it as like
operations in these tables and you could
do it very visually and you could do it
almost essentially just mouse-driven
right and it could look like excel we
sort of ran into a bunch of roadblocks
here like I said just like a very simple
example of this is not knowing where
anything came from but as you started
building up these more complex tables
you you realize that people don't really
think of the data this way they're like
they have to think about keys a lot
right and like joining on the keys and
it was still pretty hard it wasn't it
wasn't the right solution and it was
shortly after this one they were like
well guys I don't know yet about how to
do the whole like make this thing
accessible but can we at least prove
that it's a good idea right that the
foundation of this is a good idea
because we had essentially broken this
problem up into several problems the
first was could we find a version of
programming that was very simple right a
brand and by that I mean of few parts
and that version of programming has to
be something that I could use as well as
it's going to work on excel like
problems too right so had to be a
general-purpose language but I needed to
be very simple and so we really really
liked the the stuff out of the boom lab
and we had built some interesting things
but we wanted to deal with it more we
wanted to really try and develop some
stuff with it and see what happened and
so we built this prototype which given
how much time do I have
not too much time I'll show you very
very briefly what this looked like so we
had this thing don't worry about what
this looks like but so you know here's a
clock right we can zoom in a little bit
and everything in this language like I
said it's just like kind of like sequel
basically which is kind of this weird
way of thinking about the world where
all you're ever doing is querying and
and specifically actually you're
building views in our case which are
queries that are always up to date more
or less and so very first thing sticks a
row in a timer table which generates a
timer for me and that's what runs this
clock and then down here we have this
line which pulls in from the time table
which is what that timer
values into and then we aggregate over
that timetable to get the latest time
and then we just turn it into hours
minutes and seconds right and then we
draw our clock and this is just me being
bad at math and then they had this
little language down here that allowed
you to describe UI right
and we never what's interesting about
this language is you never describe how
things change basically all you're ever
doing is like asking a question and
formatting the result of that question
any but all sorts of crazy things this
way yeah we you know we built the clock
that's interesting of course we built to
do MVC right again I have to do NBC we
also built a Turing machine just to be
sure so that you know is in there and
what's interesting is once again we
bootstrapped it so everything you saw
being rendered on the right hand side
all of those tables all the UI even so
this thing was actually pushing
processes distributed so like it would
run your program in another thread and
then subscribe to that other thread and
pull data in this entire little thing
here was written in two hundred lines
this is all of it right here so again
this is like totally like crazy way of
thinking about the world but it kind of
works right and so it was from this
prototype that we started realize okay
we don't yet know how in the world we're
going to present this to people but this
seems like a pretty sound model to build
off of right there are definitely
problems that we have to figure out you
know there's performance and interesting
things there
although surprisingly if you reduce your
language to only operations on a b-tree
which is what a query language ends up
doing it ends up being pretty fast kind
of by default but there's still lots of
interesting work to do there but the
foundation is solid the foundation can
express the kinds of things we want to
express and we just have to figure out
how to show it
you know I get back to my presentation
so we try it again this time weird I
don't know why but we ended up going
back to the excel thing but this time we
had something a little bit more
interesting which was you can actually
build UI and this was the first time
that you had like a drag-and-drop UI
builder and I know that's a little hard
to see but I dragged out a button there
right and we're gonna build the
incrementer example and I'm gonna give
my button a name we'll call it
incrementer and there's this little
button down here that says get the
clicks for that button which is just a
table everything is always just a table
right if data is going to come from the
outside world it gets shoved into a
table if you want to do something to the
outside world we shove it into a table
and something and out there kind of
looks for it and does something with it
is every time I click I got a I got a
row in this table and then the
incrementer button is just counting the
number of rows in the table right and
this had that excel thing going on so
you wrote like an excel formula in here
and you said count them and then you
could just drag that column onto the
button and that was now bound now it's
sort of like data bound it to the button
and yeah I was asking me what to bind it
to bind it to the text and an
incrementer button so what a problem
that took we would take a professional
programmer easily 30 minutes to do
assuming they knew what they were doing
and if they don't who knows how long
could take 30 seconds right like we
could be much better at this if we
thought about the problem slightly
differently that one again suffer from
the same problems that I described
before which was that you lost all the
context when you're building up these
tables and it didn't really fit the
model very well so we tried this other
thing we're like hey the UI builder
thing worked out pretty well let's clone
Foursquare let's clone a
production-ready website and see what
that looks like and we built each time
right we build a new Eve to try and do
this trying to try and understand it we
test it with people this one was good
enough to build the production-ready
clone of Foursquare it was abysmal doing
it oh it was really really bad although
not because of the UI editor that worked
out really well but the way we wrote
queries in this was really awkward we
tried to mix the
- so we had the tables right and then we
had the the information basically the
sources of all the information from the
tables up at the top and it kind of
looked like a equally looking language
you were just bad it's hard to explain
exactly what was so bad about it until
you use it and you like fully realize
exactly how bad it is I don't have
enough time to show it and I don't want
to be ashamed so I'm gonna skip that one
but it was still interesting it was it
was the first time we did not have to
write any code to build a real website
right like you could do this purely
without typing anything more or less
which was interesting again but it just
it still wasn't right so the next step
after this was what we we initially
released so we're all open-source and
this is what we we pushed out when we
open sourced and it was based on this
intuition that well all of our attempts
of writing query is not in a query
language that a programmer would
understand have kind of been crappy but
we had this intuition that when we
passed around queries to each other we
drew them on the board and we drew them
as what looked like entity relationship
diagrams if you know what those are
little bubbles with you know lines
between them and we realize well if we
draw them that way to explain them to
each other could we make them work and
we hesitated going in this direction
because we know lots of problems with
this kind of visual programming and we
had even built the you know the boxes
and arrows version of this long you know
early in our process and realized this
is not going to work but this is a very
different property because what you're
describing is not a set of steps or a
data flow you're describing a shape
you're saying I am looking in the
database for a shape right and
specifically this is a famous shape it's
known as the three click query or the
triangle of friends basically a friend
was a friend of a friend was a friend
right this happens to be a notoriously
difficult thing in databases to optimize
for and you'll notice it has this
wonderful property I asked for a
triangle so I represent it as a triangle
this is one of the first
times that people seem to understand
relatively complex queries without us
having to explain much of anything to
them a very simple set of things and
they were like oh okay
triangle of friends it's a triangle
right and then you know here's a
slightly more complicated one where
you're getting the you know you have a
bunch of departments and you're trying
to find out what percentage of the total
cost each department is there's a bunch
of aggregations going on in here and
then you're dividing those to get the
percentage and this was really
interesting because like I said it was
the first time people could understand
it it didn't suffer from the same same
scaling problems that dataflow like
visual dataflow languages do because
your shapes never get that big right
it's not like you're describing the
entire flow of a program which could be
you know of infinite size basically
these were you're only ever asking for
some shape and it looks roughly like
this and so it seemed to scale halfway
decently it was really hard to build
systems in it though and we learned that
this focus on individual queries and
results wasn't really the right thing it
sort of it took you away from what you
were actually carrying though which is
the data right you're always asking your
question to get an answer back and this
focused a lot on the question and a lot
less on the answer and these like units
ended up creating these like silos that
you then did a lot of back and forth
with it was a lot like how you deal with
you know if you're building a program
and you have a bunch of different files
right and you're like going back and
forth because the functionality you want
is across four or five different files
well you have the same problem in this
but exacerbated where you know it's like
only looking at one function at a time
right okay so we zigzag because that's
what we did and we tried hey let's take
the Madlib looking thing the fill in the
blank sentence thing let's put it in a
notebook like the very first one let's
focus a little bit more on the answer
and let's make it a little bit more
visual and let's see what happens three
with this and this was interesting
because this one would allow you could
actually like talk to it so we did this
I put this I got it running on my phone
and phones have dictation on the
now as you can literally just like tell
it a query right and it would just give
you an answer back which is really
interesting and cool like that's a
compelling place to eventually be but we
found that unlike in like the Jupiter
case we're kind of like writing out the
set of steps you got to an answer for
we're talking much more like these are
alive right they're changing they're
there they're not captured in time so
the linearity of a notebook is a really
bad solution to this problem because it
implies that this then this then this
then this which is not true in this
world right so you might do something at
the bottom that would totally change the
first thing and that didn't fit the
didn't fit the model very well and also
it still feels like programming you're
still kind of doing this joining stuff
you had to know the names of the things
you were looking for right not the names
of like Chris but like the names of the
relations is friends with or you know
has a house right which again is a hard
thing because who knows what they are if
you didn't write them you kind of have
to guess and yeah we could build tools
that help you navigate that but you're
talking about lots of them it's just
doesn't matter what tools you have right
okay so we love the foundation we still
hadn't figured any of this like UI stuff
out we tried we had built basically 30
versions of Eve at this point right and
we were like okay we're clearly doing
something wrong what what assumption are
we starting from that's screwing us up
and I think you're the assumption was
and once we threw it out it like cleared
things up a bunch was that we were still
approaching this as if we were building
a programming environment right and the
idea wasn't - it wasn't really to make
programming environments right the idea
was to enable a thinking tool and a
thinking tool doesn't have to look like
a programming environment so stop
basically and where we are now and the
thing that we've decided to commit to
because it's tested extremely well and
we're extremely excited about it
it doesn't look like programming at all
not even a little bit so I'm going to
show it to you
a little bit so we have this box and
it's kind of like a search box it's just
a really fancy search box more or less
so I'm in the system if we look up Chris
Granger there's not a lot about me here
I'll make it a little bit bigger it's
not a lot about me but it says you know
I am an employee at Kota wah that's the
company that we run I have a salary of
20 which is way too high we'll change
that I have a salary of two so this is
actually kind of like a wiki
interestingly enough if you know much
about wiki's this is what's called a
semantic wiki with some changes to it
that make it a lot more powerful than
semantic wiki's typically are but the
idea here is important one of the things
we found every time we focused on the
excels like way of representing things
was that people don't think of their
data as like tables a lot of the time
right a lot of the data that we really
want to put into a system for thinking
yeah some of it is going to look like a
table you should be able to do that but
a lot of it doesn't a lot of it's stuff
like random stuff about Chris and I'm
just going to like write random
properties that I happen to know about
him at the time write that like you know
I am and I have a salary of two and you
know you know his height is really short
right right and now tada
that data is just available there for me
now and I can start to ask questions
about it so what is Chris Granger salary
well it's - what about his height the
thing that I just add hey short right so
this has this very very fluid way of
working with information
what's interesting about it is again one
of the problems with this navigation
thing I was talking about before right
you have to know the names of all these
relations and all that stuff well in
this case they're just links right like
here are all the things that I'm related
to it even tells me down here that I'm
related to another thing called
engineering and if I go there I see the
engineering card and here all the
engineers at Kota Hwa and that's
interesting and I can like dive around
in these just like you could on
Wikipedia right and that's actually a
really interesting thing because a we
know Wikipedia works be if you could
imagine a wikipedia where all the data
was available to you to ask much more
complex questions that's a pretty
compelling idea
so for example we know that there are
departments and I can look and it says
oh there are two departments here this
is just sort of generated by the system
right if I add a new card that says it
is a department order to show up here
but let's do something interesting with
it like let's sum the salaries per
department so if you think about what
just happened there this is important
there is no direct link between
department' and salary' departments
don't have salaries employees have
salaries right but because of the way
the data is structured we can trivially
figure that out for you so that you can
say it in this very natural way right I
don't need to say well first get all the
employees then link them to the
department then group them by that and
then sum them and actually if you want
to see we can actually see exactly what
it chose to do I can pop it open and it
says oh it actually just gave you the
process I just described gather
departments gather the employees related
to those look up their salary group them
in someone but instead you just ask this
very straightforward question right and
you can see it gives us back this nice
data table here and and there's another
important thing it shows you exactly how
it got that answer so this is something
that sequel will leave you in the dust
with when you start to do things like
grouping you start aggregating all all
the aggregates are lost right all the
things you aggregated over are gone one
of the things that's amazing about this
way of working is that we know where
every aspect of the information comes
from we have complete and total
provenance information and so we can
show it to you this is exactly how we
calculated the number 16 here are the
people that went into it okay so I said
I mean that's cool we can ask questions
get an answer but this isn't programming
yet you need to be able to format the
results into something interesting
that's where you get programming that's
when you get change and stuff so the way
we do that is just by adding a card so
we call these cards and we want to do is
we want to say this is like a
placeholder we want to take the
department for each department up there
right and we're gonna say something new
about that department we're gonna say
well that department
has a total cost and that total cost is
equal to the sum that we have there and
you'll see now we have this little card
down here and nothing looks like it's
changed but if we go back to engineering
you'll now see there's a new value down
here at the bottom of this car this is
engineering has a total cost of 16 I can
now compute over that so we can start to
say departments with their total cost
right it's just new information and so
this is like almost like a wiki where
you can ask a question and then generate
new information as a result of that and
that is enough to build anything you can
build compilers this way you can build
websites this way you can do all sorts
of crazy stuff what I think is the most
compelling is that you don't need to
build an application to do anything here
for the most part you could just work in
this right you could just sit here and
continue to ask questions and set up
these little rules that you have to do
very interesting things so for example
let's go back to Chris and let's make my
salary crazy again
just way too much money right and if we
go back to let's get the total cost of
departments you know it doesn't really
matter how I write this for the most
part total cost of the department's
you'll see it's 34 and actually you know
what let's let's change this around and
we'll say that departments with a total
cost greater than 20 all right so this
is actually a full query language you
can write all sorts of crazy stuff in
here and what we'll say is that those
departments are this department is
overspending
right and now if we go to engineering
did I not do it correctly
I forgot what I called it
and not to you're too important all
right departments with a total cost
greater than 20
and this department
so ever spending
if it doesn't work this time we'll all
right good there you go now this
department is overspending and now I can
again start to ask questions about that
get all the departments are overspending
send their heads an email right and the
interesting thing is all of this stuff
is live so if I come down here and open
another one and go back to Chris Granger
you'll see my engineering has a total
cost of 34 that's because I have this
really high salary but if I go and I
change it back to two all goes away it's
16 right this is all alive I never
described how things change as they
changed it's just abused over the data
and so I was going to show an example
here that thought was funny so there's
the Apple the recent Apple Keynote they
showed a thing that got a lot of people
really excited so they showed on the
Apple TV you can now talk to Siri and
have it find you the example the
specific query they gave was episodes of
Modern Family that contain Edward Norton
right so we can do that so we can say
episodes of Modern Family with Edward
Norton there you go that happens to be
the only one we can also say well how
about without Edward Norton how about we
count them right this this way of
working allows you to just very very
easily very fluidly just start to ask
questions and I think that the the
craziest realization for me and all of
this has been if we took a step back and
stopped thinking about this as
programming for a moment right we
managed to come up with a thing that
doesn't look like programming anymore
it's just asking questions and
formatting results and that encompasses
all of the things we want to do and that
is like a like an amazing result to me
that is that is a fascinating thing and
there are still lots of work to do here
right I'm not saying we've done it and I
have no idea really what you know
programming is going to look like in ten
years
but my hope is that you know whatever
programming does look like that it looks
nothing like the programming we have now
right the program we have now like the
last thing I want is you guys who are
trying to cure cancer who are trying to
understand the cosmos or whatever you're
doing have to worry about Unicode or
have to worry about event ordering or
you know like these ridiculous things
nothing to do with the amazing stuff you
were trying to do I don't want to look
like that at all
right because at the end of the day like
I said the real goal here is a thinking
tool and that is what we have to get
back to and it's in again it's not a
thinking tool for just me right
it's I want to remove the cards I don't
want you to have to punch the holes
anymore
and I want it to be able to think for us
all so yeah that's my spiel